starting next month the covet vaccine
will be included on the list of medical
requirements for service members
wijajang is at the white house ouija it
was actually president biden who
directed this change
good morning vlad you're right and now
he says that
the country is still on wartime footing
when it comes to fighting coven 19
and the protection from the virus will
allow the military force to operate
anywhere in the world in a new memo
obtained by cbs news secretary of
defense lloyd austin
announced that he would seek the
president's approval for the mandate
no later than mid-september or as soon
as the fda
fully approves the vaccine whichever
comes first
according to the pentagon 73 percent of
active duty personnel
have received at least one dose of the
vaccine and
62 percent are fully vaccinated
louisiana congressman clay higgins who
served in the u.s
army criticized the move
in an open letter to secretary austin
higgins wrote
biological threats come and go whereas
america
is forever and this is still america
good sir
freedom matters but the military already
requires many
other vaccinations service members who
refuse to get vaccinated could be
reprimanded or
punished but a pentagon spokesperson
says it is premature to talk about any
potential consequences
dana all right weeja thank you